basketball camp is next weekend you got  amazing potential on the court  and i can help you get there that's not  what i want dad  you never let me do what i want to do  you never let me just  do me hold up wrong floor  that will smith i got to deal with this  what in the matrix hell  [Music]  welcome king james i am the king of this  domain  this is the server-verse what'd you do  to my son where's dom  the only way you're getting your son  back is if you and i play a little  basketball  pete send this clown to the rejects  [Applause]  what is this  i'm a cartoon um what's up doc  i need to assemble an elite team to help  get my son back i know what you're  looking for  a dream team ma'am shoot the ball  let's try that again shall we  king james  [Music]  introducing  and get our son back  yikes  classic welcome to the space camp  [Music]  [Music]  welcome to the space jam  [Music]